welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series I'm your host Greg
Knuckles I'm joined as always by my
co-host Eric Trexler Eric how are you
doing I'm doing well how are you I am
doing well uh if you like the podcast
make sure to like rate and subscribe uh
wherever one would do that if you're
interested in keeping up with the uh the
exercise and nutrition science content
we put out you can sign up to our
newsletter or if you're interested in
some help reaching your strength
physique performance goals you should
check out Stronger by science coaching
links to both of those things will be in
the show notes if you're interested in
getting cheap supplements for even
cheaper yet check out
bulksupplements.com and use the code
sbspod at checkout for a five percent
discount uh if you're interested in a
research review check out Mass if you
you are a newfound Refugee from my
fitness pal your your Awash uh in a sea
without barcode scanning maybe check out
macro factor that is our nutrition app
the link to that will also be in the
show notes and finally for people who
commented uh about the last episode
about me saying I'm the host and doing
the intro uh that's on you that's not on
me you need to check out the stronger by
science fireside chat lore a little bit
more in depth Eric is the host of the
regular episodes I am and have always
been the host of the Fireside Chats uh
so anyway just if you come for the king
you better not miss like you you think
you know the Fireside Chats uh but you
don't so this is this is my domain is
there like a Wiki yet where people can
get because like with Game of Thrones
there's like a whole Wiki where they can
get all the backstories and histories I
mean I I am imagine a Wiki for for the
stronger by science podcast would be uh
basically the Q a page that's already on
the website
with explanations of our like three
inside jokes yeah yeah
so as everyone knows really not inside
jokes just obvious running bits yeah the
the podcast co-host Union that you
founded uh got really aggressive when we
were at the uh at the discussion
bargaining table
and
overreach pretty aggressively but you
are technically in the eyes of the law
uh the host of the Fireside Chats that
is true correct
um with with regards to last week's
episode
I have a big clarification uh because I
was thinking about it after we recorded
I mentioned my disinterest excuse me I'm
I'm the host of this okay all right so
now let's transition into the
clarification segment of this show all
right take it away yeah so I I mentioned
that I have a general disinterest and
lack of curiosity when it comes to
gadgets and even the most basic of
Technologies and I didn't provide the
most effective examples to really
clarify that so A few things that I
think really solidify that point uh I
was an extremely late adopter for
smartphones I I truly did not want one
until my parents essentially insisted
because we were on like a family phone
plan and they're like well we are all
getting them and it's going to change
our plan so like you must have one now I
got that phone and I kept it for 10
years hell yeah which in smartphone
years is 150 years uh and it got to the
point I'm sure you recall when we we're
Alpha Testing for macro Factor Corey and
Rebecca are developers when I brought my
phone out they treated it like a museum
exhibit they're like oh my God I didn't
know these were still supported are they
still supported and that was like one of
our biggest development uh like our
Fail-Safe was like if it works on Eric's
phone it will work on every phone in
existence that isn't essentially a
rotary phone yeah uh so yeah I had an
iPhone 5 for like 10 or 11 years and
then it eventually died and I went to
the store and said do you have anything
that is very close to this uh and I've
got a phone that was like four years old
or something uh same thing even with
basic things like glasses I've had the
same pair of glasses for 13 years I
don't have a backup pair I've just been
living on the edge like that and I'm
like I'm sure it'll be fine forever and
so far it's been fine it sounds good but
I'm sure if I ever go to the eye doctor
they're going to be like hey you have
you not been to the eye doctor in like
half a decade and I'll be like yeah
that's that that's correct do you wear
contacts uh sometimes okay uh what what
I do with contacts uh God someone who
knows Something About Eyes is gonna
absolutely destroy me for this but I
basically got like the single day use
ones yeah and I got five years worth or
no no I got a Year's worth but I usually
can use a Year's worth of contacts for
like five or six years nice yeah so I I
went to the the eye doctor 13 years ago
and then like six years ago and I've
been fine with all of my all of my
vision related needs but I'm sure
somebody's listening is just like oh my
God what is wrong with him uh another
simple one I use my headphones daily
um but my biggest complaint has always
been like they're Bluetooth compatible
but there's not a cord and sometimes I
really want to plug them in yeah and I
was also annoyed they don't have like a
carrying case so I beat them up when I
put them in the gym bag put them in my
backpack uh so I just made peace with
those limitations and didn't really uh
investigate further it turns out they do
have a cord and a carrying case I just
forgot I had no I had no idea uh so yeah
when it comes to gadgets and
Technologies I just like get something
that fulfills the basic use case and I
never explore it further yeah
um now moving on to new stuff actually
before we move on to that one one more
announcement should have made this at
the top of the show uh if you're
listening and you're like hey I I'm here
for science exercise nutrition content
another fireside chat wins wins the
normal programming coming back that will
probably be next week or the week after
as we mentioned on the last episode
we're trying out a new tech setup if you
watch on YouTube you you probably saw we
now have a three camera setup going uh
and so you know we're we're doing some
Fireside Chats to ensure that that we
can work out the Kinks
um the setup process for this week was
much smoother than the setup process for
last week and the video quality this
week hopefully should be better than the
video quality last week so I think we're
pretty close to being able to transition
into normal episodes if something goes
disastrously wrong this time there might
be a few more fireside chats while we
continue to work out the Kinks but
assuming everything goes smoothly uh the
the regularly scheduled programming will
be returning soon yeah I have high hopes
for this episode last episode what we
brought to you the viewing audience was
a joke it was a travesty it was beneath
the standards that you've come to expect
and we fired a lot of interns because of
that so so we really cleaned house and
we expect that this episode is going to
be much better or we're going to have to
find an entire additional cohort of
interns so we'll see correct
um but yeah so moving on before we get
into some of the the
questions from listeners there was an
image going around on Twitter uh and I'm
gonna link it in the show notes
it is a digital rendering of what
Aristotle would have looked like in the
flesh uh and it's it's awesome first of
all but this the reason I bring this up
is because I saw three comments on what
Aristotle looks like
number one the unanimous fan favorite
was Greg it turns out that Aristotle and
Greg I wouldn't say that you guys look
like twins but you look like very close
Brothers I had I had no fewer than 30
people send that to me yeah so that it
was it's a striking resemblance you have
to acknowledge that uh other things that
came up some people said I love an oddly
specific uh looks like analogy uh or
connection so someone said it looks like
that Aristotle looks like an offensive
lineman specifically for Iowa's football
team yeah and that's actually extremely
true yeah that checks out for sure that
is perfectly true in an oddly specific
way so yeah Aristotle does look like an
Iowa offensive lineman he also looks
like any Buffalo Bills fan uh which I
think is also pretty true
yeah a lot of people don't know this uh
Aristotle uh contributed to many fields
of philosophy and is also the chairman
of the bills Mafia yeah yeah so it did
bring up a question that I was curious
about uh Greg do you have any
celebrities that people often compare
you to other than uh now Aristotle yeah
so
um I will note I did not really see the
resemblance between between me and and
this uh this picture that was going
around
um that could be a trickle-down effect
of I don't really know what I look like
um
I don't look in mirrors uh mostly
because I I'm just not interested like I
don't care
um people are gonna laugh at you for
that but I actually agree entirely yeah
and there have been times where I look
in the mirror and I'm like
you know I'll be like oh I have
something on my face how long has it
been there I have no idea I haven't
looked at a mirror in four days so the
the only time I look in the mirror is if
I'm having like a small existential
crisis and it's like you know like
you're you're looking yourself in the
eyes it's like time to Buck Up you
actually look in a mirror when you're
looking in a mirror metaphorically so
yeah uh if
because that sounds insane to me
so if if I'm
if I'm like feeling or experiencing
things that I'm like unacquainted with I
I feel like you know if if I was
um
you know if I was trying to get if I was
trying to get a feel for someone else
I'm going to want to be in the same room
with them I'm going to want to be able
to look them in the eyes like I I think
you can just you can pick up on a lot of
implicit information from from that
um and like I don't do that with myself
and so when I feel like man some shit's
going on I'm having a hard time
processing it I treat myself the way I
would treat another person like you know
I need I need to look myself in the eyes
like try to get a feel for like what
what's going on in that person's head
that's like looking back at me in the
mirror
um
and I'm like I don't know it every time
it's weird I'm like oh I look like that
interesting yeah so anyway I I didn't
think I looked that much like Aristotle
my wife didn't think I looked that much
like him uh but the celebrity comparison
that I have frequently gotten throughout
most of my life is Zach Galifianakis
which like I don't really see that one
either well that that one's not even
close like I see the Aristotle I don't
see that one at all I kind of think like
I I also like not not just the Aristotle
thing like if
if someone with my general body type and
a beard uh ever hits like an impressive
lift on Instagram people will just like
tag me in it be like oh at Greg Knuckles
this is you yeah and like most most of
the time there's not even a resemblance
yeah like I think I think a lot of folks
just assume that somewhat overweight
white guys with beards all look the same
yeah uh which is fine I mean that that
would make it much easier for me to get
away with crimes like there would be so
many false leads correct um but yeah so
uh Zach Galifianakis is is pretty much
it for me yeah how about you
um there were two that I would get when
I was younger
um one of them I think is way off base
the other is kind of get closer in the
ballpark but I do I do want to Express a
caveat on the front end these are very
flattering comparisons right so I think
I know why you put this segment in the
outline now but no it's these are
excessively flattering but like that's
pretty much the nature of celebrity
look-alikes like a lot of times the
celebrities are the beautiful people and
I'm merely one of the common folk so
usually with celebrity comparisons it's
like of The Beautiful People which one
do you have some basic resemblance that
that is you know connected there so one
person one specific person back in the
day used to always tell me I looked like
Mark Wahlberg and I don't think that's
accurate whatsoever I think that's I
think that's less physical and more
spiritual like you you give off the same
energy as Mark Wahlberg like when when I
see you
I say like he could have stopped that
plane from crashing into the second
tower I have no idea what you're
referring to
I I'm pretty sure it was Mark Wahlberg
claimed in like 2004 that if he would
have been on the plane he would have
stopped 911. oh God yeah I I have no
idea uh but anyway I I don't see the
result I'm gonna have to fact check
myself
um but the one that I've gotten before
again I'm not nearly as attractive as
this person and don't claim to be but I
have gotten Matt Damon which nowadays
doesn't seem
good because like time time has not been
kind to me I don't look the way I looked
when I was younger but when I was
younger and had uh longer hair I could
kind of see the resemblance there but uh
but yeah I that that's about as close as
anyone's ever gotten with a celebrity
look like for me have you fact checked
all your ridiculous claims there yeah I
did uh here's the quote if I was on that
plane with my kids it wouldn't have went
down like it did there would have been a
lot more blood or there would have been
a lot of blood in that first cat first
class cabin and then me saying quote
okay we're going to land somewhere
safely don't worry wow
that that is certainly an opinion yeah
wow okay let's move on to some uh some
listener questions how do you feel about
that let's do it
so oh yeah I grouped these uh in the
outline to be kind of uh
themed in little clusters so this one
goes along with the physical appearance
theme why don't you read it out here
yeah so so Raja Banerjee says uh what
are the different facial hair styles
you've tried what was the most
ridiculous and do you have pictures
so I don't think I have any pictures but
when I was in high school you know how
how high school kids are they just kind
of latch on to Trends and within your
high school within your insular
Community there is no alternative right
it's just everybody agrees oh this is a
cool thing that we're all doing now uh
and in my high school that was extremely
thick and long sideburns uh now here's
an interesting question what if you were
not equipped to grow sideburns didn't it
matter you just did it anyway yeah just
just go for it yeah and so when I was in
high school there was an enormous cohort
of young men with these long wispies
sideburns that looked absolutely
horrific truly Dreadful and I was one of
those uh gentlemen so I don't think I
have any pictures but I tried it and it
was nothing else just these big bushy
disgusting long sideburns and they were
off full um so that rocks I mean in
hindsight there there are worse Trends
to go along with as a young person but I
mean there were some folks who just
including myself who were really not
well suited for the look nice yeah what
about you I feel like this is a question
for you because you you have essentially
the full spectrum of facial hair
opportunities accessible to you I mean I
think you do too like you've you've got
a thick beard you just got you gotta
commit I got some stuff over here that's
not not filled in super well but it's
fine growing it longer fixes everything
like I I have a I have a pretty large
bald spot like right here but like it
always stays long enough that no one can
see it interesting well I see I had a I
had a roommate in college who kind of
scarred me he was he was a dear friend
but every time I let my beard get a
little bit longer uh because it at that
time it was lighter in color it's gotten
darker over the years yeah but he would
uh I would walk into his room and like
hang out and he would just point at the
door and say
get your gross fleshy man beard out of
my room uh like it was it was just too
too blonde looking and fleshy and it
made him physically uncomfortable yeah
you just you just don't need those
negative people in your life that's true
um
but yeah so I uh my mustache came in
quite a bit later than my beard
um and so for a while and also like I'm
I'm very particular I don't like my
mustache touching my lip at all uh and
so as a Confluence of those two factors
for a while I I wasn't rocking the beard
and no mustache look but I was rocking
the beard and considerably shorter
considerably thinner mustache look uh so
it was like a pseudo like Abe Lincoln
pseudo-amish type deal and that that did
not work for me
um
I I wouldn't be shocked if there are
pictures of that somewhere but I don't
have them on my person
um and then then I I tried a lot of just
kind of like random things as I was
shaving just like if I had to take it
down for whatever reason just for like a
day or two I would I would trim it into
something else just
for the shock value so you know I had
the the mustache like I mean that's
that's a very tame look I had the
handlebar for a little bit oh
um I had a chin strap for a couple days
douchiest look ever uh had the goatee
look a couple times
um but yeah I know for for the most part
my uh my My Philosophy around having a
beard is simply I only have one because
it's the lowest upkeep facial hairstyle
um you know I I trim my neck maybe like
once a week and I trimmed the beard
maybe like once every three or four
months and that's it like I I don't want
to shave every day I don't want to trim
with any like regular frequency
um and so like maintaining some other
sort of facial hair Arrangement which is
completely defeat the purpose of having
facial hair for me uh so yeah I've I've
done things for just like
a day or two at a time like just just as
a joke but never never anything like
consistent yeah my my beard and mustache
get longer exclusively when I've just
let myself go yeah and I'm not taking
care of myself
uh last week you should you should grow
it out I I think you could Rock like a a
pretty long beard I I'll think about it
but but uh it was like a couple weeks
ago it had gotten kind of long and I was
just wasn't taking care of it and I was
drinking uh from a faulty can like a can
of uh I've been drinking a lot of
non-alcoholic beer lately it was very
good but the can was made like something
went wrong with the production of this
can and my mustache hair
two different times got caught in the
can oh yeah it was obscenely painful
yeah uh so I was like it's definitely
time to trim uh so yeah that's just a
danger to look out for for all the all
the folks out there that is completely
Fair
all right uh so
I I see that we're touching on current
events in this episode slightly uh
Stephen mack one of the stronger by
science coaches Steven's awesome if
you're looking for coaching uh hit up
our coaching program if you get paired
with Stephen you're in incredibly good
hands uh but yeah so Steven asks uh
political takes what are your thoughts
on student loan forgiveness yeah I've
seen a lot of folks in the fitness space
uh commenting on this uh with a variety
of different opinions and perspectives
which is usually we don't put a lot of
like directly political stuff in in into
the show but in this case I I feel like
in so many different Industries and
sectors people are kind of weighing in
but for those who aren't aware uh
in the United States
education is prohibitively expensive uh
and so a lot of folks need to take out
pretty considerable loans in order to
afford higher education
um and recently the uh the government
passed a thing that that forgave uh for
a lot of people a portion of their loans
and restructured uh the way that that
loans were getting paid back and things
like that so my personal perspective I
got really lucky uh to be clear didn't I
I don't claim to have earned it uh
through force of will and exceptional
talent I got super lucky
um and was awarded a scholarship that
made it such that I could afford College
without having to burden myself with
enormous amounts of debt uh my
girlfriend uh is in a similar situation
but she actually is smart and talented
so my mine was mostly luck I might get
into that story later uh but she also
was in a position due to academic
scholarships did not have to burden
herself with these enormous loans so I
have no skin in the game I have nothing
to gain from this policy getting passed
uh but I'm really stoked about it and
and fully supportive
um you know it's I I think the way that
people have to take on these extremely
large loans so early in life and then
they just have to bring them through
their young adulthood like this enormous
trailer that they're pulling I I think
the way that the system is currently set
up is is really predatory and so I'm
really stoked to see that people are
getting some relief from that I I would
love to see an even more extensive uh
approach to this loan forgiveness that
went a little further but I do think
it's important to acknowledge that it is
a nice first step and there are some
some aspects to this I I haven't looked
into it in extreme detail but from what
I've heard about it I think it's a step
in the right direction which is which is
nice I I agree also uh you know I I
referred earlier in the episode to
podcast lore part of the podcast lore is
this is of course a Conservative
Christian Family Values podcast and as
such I think that I don't know maybe we
should take a peek at Deuteronomy 15 the
concept of the Year of Jubilee I think
this is a good first step but just clear
all debts every seven years that's
that's that's what God wanted I think
that's what we should do but no uh
serious answer I I'm uh
very very much in agreement with you
um I also was able to go to undergrad
for free
um also from from scholarships that uh I
I didn't have to do much to to acquire
um and yeah so I I think that like like
looking at the trajectory of my life
at graduation there were
a lot of doors open to me that wouldn't
have been open if I was in a fair a fair
bit of debt and there were a lot of
decisions I made that carried low risk
that would have carried considerably
more risk if I was in a lot of debt
coming out of undergrad
um
and I I
maybe this is a wild idea uh I just want
other people to have access to the same
opportunities that I did
um and so like I I think that
I don't know like this this is maybe
like a somewhat spicy take but from in I
don't want to paint with too broad of a
brush not everyone would fall into it
would fall under this umbrella caveats
that you're that you're piling up here
is making me very nervous yeah whatever
whatever it doesn't matter uh but so
there there is a particular type of
person that would that would and does
object to student loan forgiveness that
would also
um very much say well look we we want
equality of opportunity but like the
crazy progressives or the crazy leftists
they want a quality of outcome and
that's bad but a quality of opportunity
that's good we should all support that
and like I don't I don't see how
expecting people to either come from
means or take on
a lot of debt or not attend college like
like those being the three paths I don't
see how that comports at all with any
concept of a quality of opportunity
um
and so yeah like I again this this could
be a wild idea but I think that uh
you know the the routes
that are available to people when they
get out of high school and they're
making a decision about what do I want
to do next do I want to go to college do
I want to go to Tech School do I want to
go right into the workforce whatever
like I think that
all of those Avenues should be available
to people and there shouldn't be
differing amounts like like differing
levels of needing to mortgage your
future to pursue one of those routes
um so yeah like I think this is a great
first step uh but I also think that uh I
don't know maybe there there needs to be
some systemic changes so that like
college and trade schools are free or
effectively free
um and and far more accessible to people
yeah
um I I agree that it's really important
the point that you made about
um
how uh different funding opportunities
for college impact what you do in those
critical years immediately after the
undergraduate degree and you know for me
like what I have felt comfortable
wandering into
five or six years of grad school and say
I don't really know how much money I'll
make on the back end but this stuff
seems interesting I'd like to get in the
lab it's like well if you're walking out
of your undergrad degree with you know
this enormous loan and you're like well
I need to start paying this thing off
immediately uh yeah it very much shapes
what kind of paths are in front of you
as you move forward to that next step
yeah which is which is unfortunate that
people uh are are so frequently unable
to pursue things where they could do
things that are really fulfilling and
really beneficial to society you know
because they're stuck saying well I need
to make money and I need to do it now
yeah
um yeah you want to move on to the next
one yeah let's let's I have this habit
there's a different podcast called The
Stronger by science podcast that I host
and I'm I'm just I have a tendency to
grab the steering wheel if we if we stay
on this topic
you know what we talk about off Mike if
we say on this topic I would eventually
get myself in a lot of trouble so we
should probably carry on yeah uh okay
Anthony Pletcher asks what is the
biggest what if moment in your lives
what small event completely could have
changed the trajectory of your life
unknowingly
you know so so for me um the reason I
kind of grouped these together in the
outline is I I alluded this to this
story in the previous answer
um but for me it wasn't unknowingly like
it was it was a pretty clear like major
momentous thing that happened in my life
but I mentioned my undergraduate
scholarship was uh I considered
considered to be entirely lucky with
maybe just an ounce of strategy behind
it but I I was uh due to just basic
stuff GPA uh standardized test scores
Etc invited out to this competition and
didn't really know what the competition
was like I didn't know what the what was
going to be happening you know as far as
I could tell it could be a talent show
for all I knew and so I'm thinking
probably like a math test and maybe like
an English test or something but they
actually just say like all right you
have to write two essays here's a sheet
of paper there's three prompts on the
front three on the back pick one of each
and go for it and I look around the room
and I'm like I am not the smartest
person in this room and I'm not close
like I'm not I'm not even near the top
of that of that range so
I basically said well I'm not going to
outsmart the room and just have you know
the most intelligent essay but I could
write two absolutely deranged essays and
the people reviewing them will either
think this this person is a genius a
creative Mastermind we need a person
like this in our school or they're gonna
say oh my God who submitted this uh and
I just rolled the dice I was like
whatever I'm gonna go just kind of off
the rails with this thing and uh and
yeah I went for it and uh you know the
people who graded it must have thought
it was nice and like I said I mean that
little decision of like should I try to
play this straight or just go just go a
completely different direction uh ended
up you know really dramatically shaping
what kind of avenues were were available
ahead ahead of me and yeah just
completely dumb luck really do you
remember what what the prompts were and
what your responses to those prompts
were yes yes uh so so one of them was
about like uh forecasting a type of
technology that you think will be a
really impactful in the future in the
next you know some amount of of time
frame uh on the other side it was like
uh I forget I think it was if Beethoven
was was making music today what kind of
music would he make uh and so my hope my
gamble was that the same person would be
assessing both yeah and so for one of
them I talked I basically Drew up this
um
completely
horrific uh dystopian future that just
completely ran amok due to genetic
engineering like I just went went so off
the rails with it yeah that I would hope
anyone reading it would be severely
unsettled you know uh and for the other
one I said I'm gonna make this as
frivolous and fun as it can possibly be
so I weave this Narrative of
um Beethoven essentially playing the
role of like a DJ Khalid and just kind
of putting together these mixed tapes
with just whoever seems to be getting
the most clicks at the moment you know
who gets a lot of hype on Twitter when
they put out a single and so I I just
drew together the these two things one
of them was just the darkest most
dystopian thing the other this very
light uh you know very fun adventurous
little uh work of fiction and I was like
whoever reads this if if they see that
both of these came from the same mind
they might just be impressed nice and
that was it nice
uh so so for me uh the biggest what-if
moment of my life actually happened uh
two days ago as of the time of recording
so uh I held the door for J Cole on
Wednesday going into the gym turns out
you guys to the same gym as I do pretty
cool
um really yeah but I I didn't I didn't
say anything I didn't introduce myself
figured like he's world famous like he's
he's probably not trying to like get
recognized and like have people ask for
autographs or pictures at the gym so I
was like you know what it's fine just
hold the door for him not say anything
but you know I think what if I did and I
could have become part of his crew
um signed to dreamville records become a
world famous rapper
um but you know like all is not lost I
might have other opportunities uh but no
so my my actual answer
is
um
so the the way my wife and I met was
strange so we we were high school
sweethearts uh and I had plans to uh go
swing dancing with a completely platonic
friend uh and anyway like it you know it
was with the understanding that like it
was just his friends if anything else
came up totally fine to cancel so she
did get a date lined up for that weekend
so she canceled on me and uh like I
didn't know Lindsay like we didn't have
any mutual friends didn't have that many
shared interests but like
I thought she was cute I thought she
seemed cool uh and so I was like you
know what I'm I'm just gonna take a
swing see how it goes so I invited her
to go swing dancing with a swing no pun
intended yeah which which in hindsight
like that's
that's like a deranged first date for
high schoolers
um but anyway she said yes and uh it's
it's been great ever since and like it's
uh
it's it's hard to understate
just how positive of a thing that has
been for me
um
she is
like not to be too cheesy but like she's
the best thing that's ever happened to
me and not just from like an emotional
perspective but also from like a
self-preservation perspective uh I think
I have a lot of self-destructive
Tendencies and she is a great
stabilizing force in my life that forces
me to be a more normal human which is
very good and healthy for me uh so yeah
if if uh I didn't get stood up for for
swing dancing uh who knows what would
have happened
um but yeah so
that that that might be a little bit too
too schmaltzy but
whatever that's that's my actual answer
yeah that makes sense all right uh
Patrick Douglas says uh what is the
worst job you've ever had and what made
it the worst we we can we can reverse
order here I I see you have a lot to say
yeah
um
so so mine is being a YMCA summer camp
counselor uh and that that's for several
reasons one is like it was a summer job
like between years of school needed to
make money to like save up for the next
semester and it seemed like it was going
to be a pretty decent gig like the pay
wasn't terrible the hours were supposed
to be relatively long and sufficient to
make what I needed to anyway we show up
on day one enrollment in the summer camp
was way lower than they thought it would
be so our hours got cut by like 60 on on
day one hours and therefore wages hours
and therefore wages and uh it was also
on like a weird schedule so it wasn't
like you always worked morning or always
worked afternoon which really curtailed
your ability to find another job because
it's you know like you couldn't say like
here are the hours I'm available like it
was very touch and go
um and so like that that was rough just
like purely from just the the facts of
employment
um and then also man like kids are
exhausting
um
and it's it's not necessarily that I
dislike kids they're just a lot they
have so much energy like I I acclimated
to it over the summer but I I have never
been more tired than I was after the
first week of that job and like I mean I
I work long hours now but it's not like
as as physically taxing for sure I've
also worked very physically taxing jobs
but like a week of looking after nine
and ten year olds for for even just like
four or five hours a day in the North
Carolina Sun I will note that didn't
help man I was wore out and then finally
uh I was I was in trouble all the time
as an employee because like
they're like they're your inability to
be a good employee is is is something
we've covered before right so here
here's the thing and here here's why I'm
a bad employee so I'm interested in
getting my job done well and I feel like
I need autonomy to do that
um and you know it's it's not that I'm
unwilling to accept input from authority
figures it's that if I do the things
they say and it's a [ __ ] disaster I'm
gonna say no I'm gonna troubleshoot this
and find if something works better and
so like
in our training we were trained to
basically like uh be I think the term
was like authoritative figure so not
like authoritarian but like
I don't I don't remember all of the
nomenclature but in like part of that
was like we were essentially supposed to
like treat the treat the children as if
they were babies and like if I was
looking after the five and six-year-olds
like maybe that would have flown but
like yeah my kids were between 9 and 11
and so that's like an age where people's
brains are starting to come online and
so like you know the first week I was
like yeah you know I'll I'll try to do
uh what I'm supposed to like interact
with them by the book and like it just
wasn't going well because like they they
were at the age where like
they don't want to be treated like
babies I think that caused some amount
of resentment and like my my default way
of interacting with people is just
treating everyone as a peer
um and like that's that's one reason why
I'm pretty uncomfortable around small
children because it's like look
we can't have a conversation like you
can't speak in complete sentences and I
can tell you don't have like the
attention span to really pick up on
complex thoughts and none of their
stories are interesting yeah they're
kids are stupid yeah
um but yeah uh so I I struggle with that
but you know 10 11 years old brains are
starting to come online you can start
like actually having a conversation and
so like that's what I did and it worked
a lot better like if someone was acting
up I'd be like hey man like let's let's
talk about this you know like I I
understand you got some energy you need
to let out but you know just just keep
in mind what's going on here like
there's one of me 20 of y'all like we we
gotta we gotta figure out a way to do
this that's gonna work for everyone
um and like they were very receptive to
that and things were going pretty well
but every time one of my supervisors
would observe what I was doing uh
like they they would call me in and be
like that's that's wrong you're doing it
wrong so I but also again on the topic
of being a bad employee uh the hours
were [ __ ] the pay wasn't that good and
it wasn't like the most in demand job so
like I basically called their Bluff
um I was like
like are you going to fire me and
they're they're like no like we need you
to to keep doing this but like just just
try to do it this other way but like the
only thing I process is okay I'm not
going to get fired therefore
I'm just gonna keep doing this so uh
yeah the overall I got along great with
my kids and like that part of the job
was good but I I was in constant
conflict with my supervisors but again
like they were in a position where they
couldn't fire me so yeah it was okay
yeah for me
um you know I this I want to be careful
about how I frame this because I I don't
want to do a like complainy kind of
segment
um but I would say that like objectively
speaking if you think about what are the
characteristics that make a good job and
what are the characteristics that make
an unfavorable or or uh you know a bad
job
I I would have to say that being a grad
student was the worst job I ever had
just objectively going by the the the
the the characteristics and one of the
ways that I I work through that and like
I would go back and do it again because
it's a stepping stone it's a thing you
do to get to the job you want to do
um but but I do find it very funny that
a lot of advisors uh and a lot of
Faculty members say well you should
treat being a grad student like a job
and I'm like I think that's bad advice
because this if if you were to write out
this job description right the job
description is you by the time you get
to the end of your PhD you're still a
grad student right so at some time in
your trajectory your job description is
I need you to have a master's degree and
then two to four years of extra extra
training beyond that right and you're if
you're doing human research in many
cases you are perpetually on call
mornings nights weekends whatever
someone didn't come in for their visit
Friday guess what your Saturday plans
are canceled because you need to get
them in because it had to be 48 to 72
hours in the protocol right so like you
are perpetually on call a typical work
week between your coursework your
teaching your grading your research your
writing very often in excess of 70 hours
and the pay level no matter where you're
living in the United States is almost
always below thirty thousand dollars a
year if you put that stuff on a if you
just put that out on a flyer and said
hey go ahead and call this number for
this job no one is no one is making that
call yeah so like it the the the classic
advice is hey treat it like a job but I
I think that that advice is like well
maybe it'd be cool if we did that
globally so maybe if not just the grad
student treated it like a job but also
the university yeah said oh we're going
to treat this like a job which means
like
we're gonna make these expectations more
compatible
with what an actual job is like you know
so like there are some places in the
world that I hear that you know as you
get further along in that process you
know the gig starts getting a little bit
better as you go
um but yeah that's one of the things
that was always
um one of the things like it it's easy
to say from the outside but like if uh
someone made me uh you know a
high-powered administrator in a
university one of the things that I
think the the American University system
could collectively really improve is
just how we structure the graduate
student setup and how we calibrate their
salary expectations and things like that
their their compensation I should say
but yeah on paper it's it's a pretty
crappy job and I think it gets more
obvious toward the end
because when you're toward the end of a
PhD they're like hey you're going to
teach this 300 level class and it's also
a class that some of our faculty members
teach and so you're you're literally
doing the same job yeah uh and there's
no additional guard rails that you that
are provided for you versus them you're
doing all the same grading you're
teaching the same content and their
salary is usually four or five times
higher than yours yeah but for literally
the same thing that you're doing uh and
at that point most of your research are
doing pretty independently just like
they are and so yeah toward the end of
the gig you start to say like I really
need to get out of here yeah so I I
don't like I said I don't want to be too
complaining because like I I have no
complaints I was a grad student for a
while had a lot of opportunities put put
on a platter right in front of me I got
very lucky in that regard uh so I don't
want to make it seem like I'm over here
complaining but objectively speaking you
do get to a point toward the end where
you're like I I need to move on to
something else immediately nice but yeah
an underrated job
if you're like uh you know like when I
was in high school I had some crappy
high school jobs that I hated uh food
service was pretty tough
dude janitor at a gym was the best high
school and college gig you could ever
get I mean I was just up there mopping
away on on the gym floor and just
chatting with everybody hey how's your
bench press going hey did you get that
that deadlift the other day like it was
the best man nice yeah all right uh
Michael Taylor asks uh how about some
more conversation around Under The Radar
music that you're listening to
I I will once again go first because
your list is quite a bit longer than
mine
um
I don't I don't really seek out much new
music and most of the stuff I listen to
is like the stuff I listen to in high
school it was good then it hasn't gotten
worse over time uh and discovering new
music is a Time investment and uh yeah I
don't know I did just don't fit or don't
try to fix what isn't broken that's kind
of how I approach it uh but I will say
uh she's not super under the radar but I
don't think she's super mainstream yet I
have been listening to some Remy wolf
recently
um I saw her open for Lord a couple
months back she was very good brought
excellent energy to her live show and
said you know what I'm gonna check her
out on Spotify so I did and it's uh it's
enjoyable music so that that would be my
my recommendation good stuff uh I'm
gonna go through this really quickly
here but first a disclaimer uh by
definition I do not have Under The Radar
music because I do not have an ear to
the ground I am not part of the uh
Underground Music Scene so anything that
has gotten to me by default is not
actually under the radar so what I
wanted to do here as a true empiricist
is I just went through one of the
playlists I've been listening to a lot
lately one that I made myself and just I
was like oh what are some bands on here
that you don't hear about much uh these
days uh in in uh you know out in the
wild as people are discussing music so
just running through some names yaysayer
excellent band saw them at Lollapalooza
and they were incredible Kurt vile same
deal Solomon Lollapalooza he was great a
band called real estate uh LCD sound
system which I I don't believe they make
music anymore unless I'm mistaken but
back in the day they were they were
pretty solid grizzly bear deer hunter
pavement Local Natives uh that's one
that a lot of folks haven't heard of but
they're pretty solid Mac Demarco is
getting really big in the like Indie
music world now so and some someone is
going to just roast me for including him
on an under the radar list uh if it
makes you feel better I've never heard
of him oh well he's he's under my radar
okay he's under at least one radar yeah
but but Mac DeMarco I like his stuff a
lot uh a few bands that are are not
under the radar but um you know they
were on the playlist so I'll throw them
in there The Strokes I love The Strokes
uh Interpol had some really solid albums
uh there's a artist who goes by the name
the teever who's quite good and then one
that's just a complete curveball total
change of genre but have you heard any
music from silk Sonic
I'm sure I have I I think Lindsay has
some of them on her playlist but yeah I
I haven't sat down and like chewed on
their music yeah uh well they're great
it's a collaboration between Bruno Mars
and Anderson pack and uh it's in terms
of genre just a complete 180 compared to
everything else on the list but yeah
they've got some really nice stuff all
right moving on yeah let's do it all
right
Sean Sutherland asks what are your
favorite five movies of all time uh with
a parenthetical uh assuming Eric has
seen at least five movies LOL yeah so I
can't really do a top five movie list I
think it would be inappropriate due to
insufficient sample size as the question
gets at I just I can't offer an informed
opinion on that but I will say this I
was in a room
uh hanging out and my my brother was
like hey do you want to watch a movie
and I said absolutely not he said well
let me rephrase that I'm going to watch
a movie you can do whatever you want uh
and he put on 2001 A Space Odyssey and
the opening scene drew me in like the
most powerful magnet on the planet uh I
was blown away and like with the with
the monkeys looking at the pillar it was
yeah there's just this entire sequence
at the beginning it starts with that and
then it gets into this very ominous
conversation and you can't tell exactly
what they're talking about but you know
you want to know yeah right and so it
was very nuanced subtle filmmaking
storytelling that Drew you in without
like you know hitting you over the head
with with any really explicit details
um but yeah that movie drew me in and
was a wild ride uh so that that has to
be on the list if I were to make one but
instead of movies I'm gonna give my my
top five tele Vision series just based
on how I'm feeling lately
uh Breaking Bad was excellent it was a
classic peaky blinders I very very much
enjoyed Seinfeld is a classic uh It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia is in my
opinion kind of the the modern Seinfeld
there's some pretty clear parallels
there but my favorite Universe of
content is called on cinema at the
cinema uh and it's Greg turkington and
Tim Heidecker and uh it's it's really
difficult to explain it started out as
like a YouTube uh movie review show that
they would do in character the movie
reviews were terrible but they were
developing this kind of universe behind
it that branched out into
so many different things and it's I
don't even know where to begin in trying
to disentangle how that Universe came
together but I mean it's they've had
television shows uh a YouTube series
podcast like it's a whole it's a whole
thing at this point and
it's just a very like the term that a
lot of people would use is anti-comedy
for kind of the way they approach it
although I know Tim Heidecker uh at
least from interviews I've seen takes
issue with that because he's like it's
either funny or not and if it's funny
it's comedy right but uh it's a very
unique kind of Niche approach to Comedy
that
if a hundred people listening to this
check it out uh 97 will be like Eric I
don't get it why why are you doing this
and the other three will watch it uh for
the rest of their life and buy a t-shirt
nice yeah all right so so for me uh I I
did actually answer the question that
was asked uh that sounds like a dig at
me well it said five movies and you only
gave one I do have a question for you
yeah if you like 2001 have you checked
out any of Kubrick's other stuff
no because an irrational thing about me
that I will always defend is
I refuse to spend two hours
uh initiating the pro the process of
watching a movie I I refuse to sign up
for that commitment but if you play Four
30-minute television shows I'll watch
all four of them no problem that is
completely Fair the one thing I will say
is that if you like 2001 but don't like
many other movies there might be some
other stuff in the kubert Canon you like
because they all have a very particular
feel that's pretty unique to Kubrick's
stuff yeah in that
you like no matter how good the actors
are and what they're trying to emote on
screen there's a deep sense you get that
everyone involved in the project is
miserable yeah because they are yeah
because apparently it was hell to work
for Kubrick he would he would make
people like just do the same scene like
200 times in a row
um
and uh yeah so I I think I think with
Kubrick like you either love him or you
hate him yeah but if you like one of his
movies you you'll probably like more so
he's trying to get misery out of the
actor and he says well we don't need to
act I'll just make you miserable exactly
I'll just create it yeah like no matter
what if you were in a Kubrick film you
were a method actor yeah and you were
embodying the role of a miserable actor
yeah what we'll call it a practical
effect all right just make you extremely
miserable yes perfect uh but yeah so so
my list is uh
uh and and this isn't necessarily in
order but these are my top five uh Lord
of the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring
uh directors Edition Lord of the Rings
The Two Towers director's Edition Lord
of the Rings The Return of the King uh
director's Edition once again uh and
then for the final two and to be clear
like I I think that the Lord of the
Rings trilogy was maybe one of the
greatest masterpieces ever ever put to
film
um
so my next one I've mentioned on the
podcast before and this could just be
recency bias but I really really liked
uh everything everywhere all at once and
it it might be in my top five it was it
was uh I I found it spectacular uh and
then for the fifth spot it's hard to
narrow it down to just one but I'm gonna
say Spirited Away or really just about
anything by Hayao Miyazaki
um I think of his movies I think
Spirited Away is my favorite but there's
just a time where you have an itch yeah
you have a Miyazaki itch that only
Miyazaki can scratch
um his his movies just have such a
such like a great Ambiance and Vibe
that's uh that's fairly unique to him
and is just just incredibly Pleasant
nice yeah
all right
um do we want to do we want to move on
to some Reddit questions I feel like
we've been going kind of long
um it's up to you you're the host I'm
just here for fun
all right
um
[Laughter]
okay we we can save these for just like
another fireside chat at some point I I
think we have like another whole
episodes worth of questions picked out
yeah but I do want to go for two Reddit
questions I would say so as to not
neglect that Community
um
yeah let's go for some random ones so uh
Ulrich asks you're being sent back to
Florence Italy in the year 1000 CE
leaving in 12 hours you will be provided
travel clothing basic camping gear and
an empty medium backpack you don't know
if you'll ever return to this time uh
you'll get military vaccines but once
you arrive you're on your own you can
bring one item with you as long as it
fits in the backpack you can bring
multiple of the item as long as
everything fits in the backpack your
mission is to accelerate human
civilization what do you bring
uh I have to go after you because my my
uh my answer is basically just building
upon yours yeah because I think you got
the correct answer yeah so I I think the
the obvious uh answer is just a physics
textbook and and be Discerning about it
like try to find ones that include like
relatively detailed descriptions of how
the early experiments were done and how
the early discoveries were made because
like you know [ __ ] like electromagnetism
like you could you could give someone
from a thousand CE like the equations
and they'll be like what the [ __ ] is
this yeah uh and like I don't I don't
know how they initially discovered that
but like a good physics textbook that
takes you through both like the
implications of how to work with these
forces but also just like how they could
go about independently like verifying
them uh I I think that that's probably
the play uh and then you couldn't take
these in a backpack but just in terms of
things I would try to teach them I would
try to teach them about crop rotation
because
Europeans specifically were really late
to the game on crop rotation like when
people talk about the Dark Ages they're
like ah like nothing really happened
things were great in the Roman Empire
and then ah like all all technological
progress stopped like that's that's not
true uh and if anything like one one of
the most important technological
breakthroughs made uh was crop rotation
during the Middle Ages and that's like
one of the things that allowed
populations to start exploding just
because like before that people would
just plant Fields every year eventually
just run them out of nutrients and then
just kind of starve
so uh teach them about crop rotation and
teach them about germ theory of disease
that seems like a pretty big one uh and
I do know how how Pastor demonstrated
that so I could I could walk them
through it as long as they had like
reasonable quality glassware yeah
yeah I think that you are largely
correct in terms of what you're trying
to achieve there but one thing I'll
point out uh it says you can bring one
item with you it leaves some room for
interpretation there I believe you could
create the item in my opinion and so
what I would do is take kind of like a
scrapbook approach to the materials that
I'm putting in my backpack so uh I think
you you hit the nail on the head because
the goal here is to accelerate human
civilization right so physics textbook
very big crop rotation germ Theory what
I would try to do is put together a
little binder so yeah here's like kind
of a crash course in what you can expect
over the next uh you know thousand years
or so so I try to throw in some stuff
about how vaccines work maybe uh drop
drop a little hint about antibiotics in
there electric light seems important but
probably one of the the single thing
that I think would you know kind of
achieve that that goal of accelerating
human civilization I'd say hey printing
press is coming along in several hundred
years but like you might want to get a
head start on that so I I would I would
try to prioritize the printing press and
say you you want to you want to do this
this will be nice that's smart yeah all
right uh let's let's end on uh let's end
on the trolley problem Oh God so uh what
you expect uh said uh I'm gonna be
boring and just invoke the trolley
problem it's been overdone to death but
usually has it has generated at least
some authentic ideas each time I've
heard it discussed through through
various media and then dark Autumn adds
that uh one of one of like the classic
versions of the trolley problem is like
okay like maybe you're willing to pull
the lever but what if instead of pulling
the lever you had to push someone
physically push someone onto the tracks
to stop the trolley still killing one
saving five would you do it many people
say they wouldn't but apparently one of
the groups that pretty consistently or
two of the groups that pretty
consistently say they would I haven't
checked the sources on this I'm going to
assume that that this user dark Autumn
isn't lying to us uh but apparently two
of the groups that would push the person
onto the tracks are psychopaths and
Buddhist monks so they were particularly
interested in how Eric would respond to
that and just the trolley problem in
general so uh that's kind of a peek
ahead but let's just start with the
basics so I'm sure most most listeners
here are aware of the trolley problem
but if not here the the most basic setup
is that a trolley's coming down the
tracks there's five people tied to the
tracks there's no way you can get there
to untie them and save them uh either
the trolley is going to run them over or
you can pull a lever divert the trolley
to another set of tracks there's one
person tied up to that set of tracks you
also can't do anything to save them uh
you know they're not going to get away
so basically do you allow the trolley to
keep just going straight not take action
and allow five people to die or do you
pull the lever divert it to the other
tracks and allow one person to die but
you know the uh like how how much do you
value
uh like bad things happening due to your
inaction versus bad things happening due
to like an active action that you take
so yeah Eric do you do you pull the
lever
so I do uh and I have many times uh and
I think to me it comes back to my uh my
my old teaching uh that I was doing so
back in uh when I was teaching a sports
medicine class uh at the University
level we would have to talk a little bit
about
um legal ramifications of uh failing to
uh you know uh complete your task in the
sports medicine field with a
satisfactory level of competence right
so we would talk about uh lawsuits
related to negligence and you know you
can look at acts of omission which is
you know failing to do what you have a
duty to do I'm paraphrasing here off
memory uh and then acts of commission
where you do a bad thing and it's like
dude you should not have done that but
both of those things are routes to
negligence and harm right and so I think
this really gets at the idea of
do are you so averse to an act of
commission you know pulling the lever
and doing anything that causes a death
you know you're kind of I guess
balancing like the guilt uh that comes
with an act of of commission of doing
that thing versus uh you know the the
fact that by doing that you know you can
no longer claim to just be hands off and
say well it was an act of omission yeah
but you know at the end of the day we're
talking about one life being lost or
five right so I I think uh I would pull
the lever because I think the
distinction between one life and five
lives is much more impactful than the
distinction between an act of omission
and an act of commission yeah I I fully
agree
um I I pull the lever and I I mean who
who knows how I would respond if if I
was actually in that situation but in
terms of just here in this room just
talking about it theoretically uh yeah I
pulled the lever and and I don't have to
think too hard about it so my excuse is
that I'm a Buddhist what's what's your
excuse but you're a psychopath
I don't I don't think I have like a
super cons well so that that's the
that's the next iteration of this one oh
okay but in in terms of just in general
how how I look at this
I don't think I have a super consistent
set of ethical principles but I do think
if I have kind of like a default mode of
how I operate
um I I think I have like some core
principles that kind of like transcend
General ethical decision making to me so
like one of those is loyalty
um like if if you're one of my people
like I've got your back uh
almost no matter what
um
so like they're they're kind of like
those big overriding principles kind of
like that but then when it comes down to
like kind of more day-to-day ethical
decision making I'm pretty utilitarian
like that's that's kind of the way I
lean so for
I mean most of the time I pull the lever
for for most iterations of the trolley
problem all right so now let's get into
the one that uh that dark Autumn asked
about in particular so now instead of uh
instead of just the train barreling down
the tracks and you can pull a lever to
divert it you can either just let it
keep rolling uh there's there's no lever
to pull there's no second set of tracks
but you're standing on a bridge and
there's another person standing on on
the bridge and you can push them in
front of the trolley and and that will
stop it uh and you know this is a
philosophical question so like you can't
say oh well it wouldn't actually stop
the trolley like you know with perfect
knowledge that pushing this person in
front of the trolley will stop the
trolley but now you're actually shoving
a person instead of pulling a lever do
you do you do that one you know I I
think um again it's easy to do like a
little thought experiment like this and
answer a certain way um you know whether
or not you would actually do it in the
moment when the adrenaline's rushing is
is very different I think it'd be harder
in that situation but uh when you're
when you're discussing it as a
hypothetical I would still say yeah I
mean that
it it again is you know uh an act of
commission rather than Omission but one
that ultimately saves a net of four
lives uh so I I don't think that the
concept of uh you know a push being a
much a much more terrible act than a
lever poll I I don't think that that
really changes the calculus that much to
me you know like I I know that we we
have the kind of built-in uh mental
concept that like yeah pushing someone
is a not nice thing and is is a more
aggressive action than pulling a lever
uh but but I I really don't think that
logically it changes the calculus that
much okay uh so I I agree so I guess
that makes you the Buddhist and me the
psychopath yeah I think so
um
I'm that scans whatever uh okay so
you know those those are the the two in
particular we were asked about there
there are many other iterations do you
have an iteration of the trolley problem
that you would like to throw at me I
know I I never heard of the trolley
problem until uh I saw it in the outline
really yeah I've never heard of it oh
[ __ ] okay let's have some fun then okay
all right so now uh you know the
original version of the trolley problem
five one pull the lever kill one say
five but the person on the tracks is
um say like a either like your
girlfriend or a parent best friend close
family member something like that I hate
where this is do you pull the lever then
oh man
um you know what
I I did look at the link that was
talking about how the the Buddhist monks
answered to this and I'll probably get
kicked out of of my Sangha for this but
ah man like you said loyalty really
starts to mess around with your like set
of of ethical kind of uh
things you know like
who it'd be re it'd be really hard right
so like if someone you care about is on
that other area of the tracks and you're
pulling the lever to divert the train or
the trolley toward them
uh I I don't think I could do it if I'm
being honest with myself and I know that
the the monk said that that's a selfish
approach and and one that's not uh one
that's not uh
supported by them yeah that that's fair
so I also don't pull the lever
um and as as someone with vaguely
utilitarian leanings uh I I actually
think you can make a a utilitarian
argument for that so you know the the
idea of like maximizing
[Music]
like net happiness minimizing that
suffering I think that sometimes in like
a utilitarian calculus and and I'll
readily admit that this sort of thinking
kind of kind of opens the door for
people justifying just about anything
they want to but I do think you need to
consider kind of like second and third
order effects and I kind of think that
like
one of the core tenets of
having like a functioning Society is you
need some amount of trust and a lot of
trust is is built on uh like familiarity
basically like you you you have to have
like a general understanding that like
you you look out for your family you
look out for your friends and like there
are relationships that matter to you and
so I guess I guess this is almost like
viewing a utilitarian decision through
like a deontological lens but I I sort
of think that like if people were to
generalize that and it's like okay well
what if what if people did just start
pulling the lever in that situation and
like as like a default setting where
everyone's like oh of course yeah we all
pull the leverage right and like you you
could you would therefore have much less
trust that the people who you care about
and who you think care about you would
have your back in a in a sticky
situation yeah I think the knock-on
effects of that would be disastrous so
yeah that's a good point in that
situation I I would not pull the lever
anything to confirm my biases and make
me feel less selfish for my previous
answer I'm fully in support of cool yeah
no I yeah I'd never heard of these uh
I've heard of like iterations of them in
hindsight but I'd never like heard of
them categorized as like the trolley
problem or this like kind of I didn't
know it was a thing yeah I just thought
it was a a random collection of thought
experiments that I've encountered well
let's keep rolling let's do God I hate
this let's do like two or three more
because those are those are the three
classic trolley problems okay um
so let's see so this is this is also a
classic iteration uh and is
and is one that is probably more likely
than the ones we've done so far to at
least make some people upset
all right so now it's not five and one
it's one and one uh the train is
barreling down the tracks uh and it's
it's gonna hit a person who you know you
don't know anything about them but they
appear to be say below 30 years old or
you can pull the lever and it'll divert
it to a track where you don't know
anything about the other person but they
appear to be maybe like 80 years old oh
God
do you pull the lever uh uh I don't know
I can't think of a good way to answer
that I I hate these I don't like them at
all
what do you what do you do I mean
so I
I also don't feel good about this but I
don't think
and and someone could persuade me
otherwise about this
but I don't think that I view
acts of commission and acts of omission
differently like I I do think that they
carry the same moral heft yeah
um
and so I I don't I don't think you get
out of it by not pulling the lever right
and I do think that
I I do think that just in general
um
the the potential for continued life has
to be valued to some extent yeah
um and so I would say like just on a in
terms of like who deserves like moral
consideration
um I don't think that like age impacts
someone's uh like inherent worth but I
do think that if you're in a situation
where where like one has to die
I feel like you gotta pull the lever
there and and I also think that's
basically how the medical system works
like a triage system like you you know
with with finite resources if you've got
to let someone die you start with people
who have the lowest chances of survival
right and then if it's people who seem
to have similar chances of survival you
tend to just favor the younger folks
because they have more life left to live
yeah
um so I I feel like I would have to go
that route but that that's that's the
first iteration of kind of like the
classic trolley problems that does make
me incredibly uneasy it does make me
uneasy I guess you could kind of frame
it it's like okay let's say that we have
a total of 100 person years to allocate
between the two yeah does it seem uh
more fair that we say okay well you get
to live 20 and you get to live 80 or to
say okay you both get 50 years you know
you both get a crack at it right so I I
guess with it it's the same kind of deal
where it's like well you know you know
you've you've already the older person
has already had ample opportunity to
experience all the joys of Life uh and
has a a more limited one would assume
you know yeah remaining years of life so
I hate these are you sure we have to do
two or three more we're good we're gonna
do one more okay one more is fine we're
gonna do one so I I was like here's this
I know some very devious iterations of
the trolley problem I'm taking you
through the the five I would say most
classical versions okay because one
thing that you know as I've gotten more
and more into Buddhism I I've thought
more about how I attend the garden that
is my mind and whether or not I wish to
burden it with hypotheticals that are uh
anxiety-inducing or treacherous or
depressing like I I really do cultivate
very carefully the ideas that are
rattling around in my brain so the idea
of willingly subjecting myself to these
awful choices apparently a bunch of
Buddhist monks did yeah for the article
that dark Autumn linked I'm not quite a
monk yet okay uh so yeah maybe they're
they're just more more robust and
resilient they've got better training
for for navigating these Waters all
right so here here's the last one okay
actually we'll we'll do we'll do two
more uh okay and then we'll be done okay
all right all right so so this one still
five one it's the classic trolley
problem but the one person not someone
you love uh but it's someone who uh you
know is considered like a great person
who who did important things so you know
imagine it's say Albert Einstein
um and you know with like perfect
philosophical knowledge that he will
like discover and publish general
relativity and special relativity
relativity but like he hasn't yet you're
a time traveler in this scenario yeah
you know what he would go on to do if he
survived
uh but it's it's five versus one do you
let the trolley hit the five or do you
pull the lever and kill Einstein
uh and you know if if it's like the type
of thing that like it is a major
Paradigm shifter that alters the
trajectory of of human existence
I I would say you'd have to say yeah we
don't get many chances at that that
would be my my answer that's interesting
I I think I think this is the first one
that we pretty strongly disagree on well
because I'm trying to think of you know
maximizing the positive benefit of
whatever that individual so like for
example if it's if it's you know uh a
person who discovers uh some kind of
medical intervention that saves 400 000
lives you know what I mean that's where
my mind goes not just like a a some kind
of trivial uh yeah I made a little novel
Discovery but I'm I'm thinking more if
if if I know that them yeah let's say
it's uh let's say it's what's his name
Edward Jenner
uh smallpox vaccine guy yeah so like if
I know that I can save this one life
because what they're gonna do is gonna
result in tens or hundreds of thousands
of lives saved because of what they're
on the cusp of achieving then then yeah
I think I would weigh that into the
calculus pretty heavily but it sounds
like you feel differently yeah no I I I
pull that lever just as quickly as I
pull the lever in in the first canonical
scenario yeah
um
because I I fundamentally don't believe
in the great man theory of History
um I I think that
I think that there are a ton of
very smart and capable people and that
for most discoveries and breakthroughs
that are made uh like the the person
that gets there first is really just
like the person who got lucky and that
if if they didn't do it someone else
probably would have made like an
identical Discovery and like still done
the same stuff within like a decade of
when it initially happened
um because like the the way like ideas
form
very rarely do you have someone who's
just like
so so transcendently brilliant that
they're jumping like multiple leaps
ahead it's basically like their ideas
floating around like in in the general
consciousness of society or a particular
field and like the Breakthrough is just
like you're the one that figures out
like the two ideas that fit together or
like the way to just barely extend an
extant idea to to make it something like
really cool and impactful
um so yeah like I I think
Einstein for example was was a brilliant
physicist but I think that there were
hundreds if not thousands of brilliant
physicists at the time and if if he
didn't pull off
uh general relativity like someone else
would have within like three years or
something so yeah I I think that uh
yeah I I pulled the lever there yeah I
just I think it's difficult to to be a
time traveler who's next to somebody's
deathbed and saying I have great news
someone's gonna cure this in 30 years
yeah well but but the thing is like I I
really I really don't think
it's like 30 years
uh yeah I guess it the question is uh in
this hypothetical how many people are
dying and at what rate you know because
even a 10-year delay leaves a lot of
people hanging for 10 years yeah that
that's fair but I I also think that this
kind of Harkens back to what we were
talking about with like for a family
member or close friend like I think that
if you're if you start making that
calculus you start kind of
signing up for a a fundamentally elitist
Society where you are are willing to
ascend that people who have been
particularly successful have inherently
more valuable lives than other people
and I'm not comfortable with that at all
well no so because what I'm saying is
the value of the ten thousand saved yeah
not the one saved because this is a very
special person you know
yeah
um
yeah fair enough yeah are you sure
that's not the last one because I
genuinely hate this
but this you are right now the Stanley
Kubrick of podcasters the this this is
the last one I I promise you okay okay
so
um
all right so you're
the trolley's barreling down the track
at five at Five People You you pull the
lever it's gonna divert it to a track
with one person and that lever pull will
divert the track or divert the trolley
onto a a track that works perfectly and
that one person will die there are five
people on the other track but the tracks
poorly maintained it's a little rickety
uh in fact it's very rickety and there's
an 80 chance that the trolley will
actually just uh run off the tracks and
everyone survives
do you pull the lever
um
so pulling the lever puts it onto the
one where there's a 20 chain or an 80
chance pulling the lever puts it onto a
track 100 chance one person dies okay if
it keeps going there is a 20 chance that
five people die and an eighty percent
chance that no one dies
yeah I would I would not pull the lever
okay yeah I'd say let's let's see if if
the numbers work out you know
and hope for the best yeah
so I feel like you gotta give you at
least open up the the chance of of a a
really successful outcome yeah yeah so
I'm I'm with you I I so this this one I
think is the least ethically fraught
this more just gets to like how you
think about probability yeah because you
know all net if you ran this experiment
10 000 times the same number of people
die no matter which way you choose like
it it works out
um so you know it's it's basically are
are you willing to risk it to get the
biscuit yeah um but yeah once once it
goes from being a 100 proposition to a
probability game where maybe five people
die but on average if it's done enough
times it balances out I I go for the
option where there is at least a
probability that no one dies yeah yeah
yeah I like the idea of at least having
the the possibility open you know
um all right we're done with trolley
problems you can breathe easy now I hate
those because like it's yeah it just is
completely antithetical to everything
about the way I like my brain to work
yeah that's yeah that's completely Fair
um I do have one thing I wanted to
address before we wrap up was that gonna
be the last question I I think so we've
we've been running pretty long it's like
5 45. okay yeah I so I told someone on
Instagram that I would answer their
question and so I have to answer it
because I I put a Time on it okay uh an
Instagram user getting back to stuff
that makes me feel good instead of bad
uh
an Instagram user asked if I could
re-share my experience about uh getting
into Buddhism like what what the
motivation was how it was going I don't
want to like uh harp on it too much uh
as you know I quickly scampered away
from the road to Enlightenment segment
but since it's uh uh fireside chat and
it's literally the only thing I do
outside of Fitness stuff it comes up
from time to time
uh and I haven't really uh addressed it
in a lot of detail from start to finish
I'm not gonna have like a long answer
but just wanted to answer this question
for people who are tagging along and
like what the hell is going on here so I
got interested in
uh Buddhism really at the beginning of
covid uh because I mean you've known me
for several years and I never even
hinted at an interest prior to that
um but what I noticed with covid like
immediately there were all the lockdowns
which I supported I understood the the
necessity and and thought they were the
right thing to do at the time uh but you
know being on board with it doesn't is
not synonymous with enjoying it you know
and I noticed that even for someone like
me who didn't go out and do a lot there
was I noticed that when like the gym is
closed and all the restaurants are
closed the things I would typically do
to busy my mind and find some Joy when
those were closed uh my ability to
independently generate joy and
contentment was really dramatically
impaired and so it kind of made me
realize that my ability to obtain Joy
was really contingent upon a lot of
external conditions and I was like that
doesn't seem like like a good path like
I I'd like to be able to access that joy
and general uh contentedness uh by my
own making rather than relying on a
bunch of factors outside my control so
that's what kind of got me that's what
kind of spurred me and got me into it
but I was cleaning out my house the
other day
um someone asked if we if we journal and
I don't Journal anymore but there was a
time where I was so miserable that I
started journaling a lot which I don't
understand why it was like I need
contemporaneous notes of how freaking
miserable I am right now I don't know
why that seemed intuitive I I will say
that that seems pretty generalizable
like yeah that and like
it's like I need to prove to someone in
10 years how miserable I am well I I
think that there's a and you know and
this doesn't always track but there
there's
a list of things that like people will
recommend for like you know like
self-care how to feel better what not in
like journalings one of them yeah um
like taking mental health days is
another one uh and like all of these
things that are like supposed to help
you feel good but then I kind of noticed
that if someone's doing
multiple of those things it's like
I don't think you're feeling that good
right now yeah so so what was really
funny was I was cleaning out my house
um and I found this old Journal which I
mean I'll note that that checks out like
people people have a problem they're
taking steps to remedy it uh I I
certainly don't begrudge that but yeah
yeah it is interesting though because it
allows you an opportunity it's almost
like doing mindfulness without calling
it mindfulness because it it kind of
instructs you to uh decenter yourself a
little bit and explore things and in
this case just kind of jot them down
right instead of you know meditating on
them or something uh but it was really
funny because I was looking through this
journal and like I was like this is
gonna be so cringy but I have to open it
and just go back to it and what's so
incredible is like this was years before
I even got into this kind of stuff but
it was so obvious that it was exactly
what I needed uh like I was going
through and it's like oh today I'm
journaling about how I'm not managing my
my strong negative emotions very well or
I'm not managing my anxiety about the
future very well or my regret about the
past very well or I'm always striving
and task oriented and I can't really
enjoy the present moment I'm always
chasing the next goal with so much
ambition that I'm ignoring the present
moment uh really failing to just
experience the present moment and access
Joy I'm looking through the pages and
it's so it was so painful in retrospect
because I was like dude you were so
close you
you named every problem that you had and
not a single viable solution so in that
case the journaling at the time wasn't a
particularly constructive practice
because I was just documenting misery
and never exploring any remedy for that
aside from just like ah here's a list of
miseries that I've compiled
um but yeah so it's really clear to me
that even going back before covid it it
was something that probably would have
benefited me very much because when you
get into it you notice that it does
address a lot of those topics very
explicitly and very head-on you know
um managing emotions while managing
stress and anxiety things like that so
and like one of the uh really key ideas
in Buddhism is that of aimlessness uh
that you know you don't always have to
be super ambitiously striving for the
next goal it's okay to just kind of be
there and experience life and I grew up
in the midwest man ambition is the only
virtue like growing up in the midwest
I'm sure that's true many places but
like the American Midwest is like there
are the hyper ambitious folks to whom
aimlessness sounds like a grave sin and
then there's the people who lacked
ambition which like in that cultural
environment it's like the worst thing
you could be and someone without
ambition and they become the cautionary
tale yeah for everyone else yeah yeah
and so like yeah it was just uh getting
into these ideas was a complete um I had
to completely revisit and in some cases
restructure the way that the way that I
viewed certain perspectives and mindsets
but anyway yeah it was really funny to
take that that trip down memory lane and
covid was what nudged me over The Edge
to actually start pursuing these ideas
um but it was always there even years
before where I'm like ah that could have
been helpful but someone asked about how
I got into it and like the the content I
started with
I listened to Buddhism guide which is a
podcast by Karma yeshi RAB gay which was
really really nice I really liked that
then I started reading his books and
then I ran out of his I read all of his
books and I said well what are more
books and then I got into ticknot Han's
books and his particular tradition of
Buddhism really really resonated with me
like I I love yashi's stuff it was
really really helpful to me and I still
think it's great but tick not Han stuff
resonated with me at just a completely
different way uh so I ended up joining a
Sangha that's a couple a couple blocks
over that practices in the tradition of
ticknot Han which is really cool uh and
I still listen to a lot of stuff I
listen to a podcast called Audio Dharma
which is a collection of lectures that
are that are really really good and uh
so yeah if you're interested in just
kind of tiptoeing into some of these
topics and exploring what they're all
about those are the resources that I
would highly recommend and you know if I
were to go back and I I really you know
all of these different sources really
have helped me solidify things in
different ways but if someone was to say
I'm just starting out I need something
that's very approachable and accessible
um something that doesn't insist that I
immediately jump on board with anything
that
is too different from the ideas I were
brought up with I would say start with
some of tick not Hans books and they're
they're really really nice and uh
they're they're very non-judgmental they
meet you where you are and you can kind
of pick and choose which elements are
are most helpful to you sweet
all right that's all I got all right so
that that does it for this episode of uh
the stronger by science fireside chat
series I hope you enjoyed it
um as always if you want to help us out
if you're watching this on YouTube make
sure to like it drop a comment and I
hear that helps the algorithm uh leave
us a nice review if you're listening to
this on any sort of podcast platform if
you have a negative review uh the the
email address to send that to is Eric
strongerbyscience.com uh to to get a
long uh very personal response to your
thoughtful criticisms and uh yeah we'll
we'll see you
almost assuredly in a week if not in a
week than in two here's a quick over
under before we close out
how many people do you think are going
to comment speculating on whether or not
Eric was obscenely uncomfortable during
the trolley problem or the greatest
actor of Our Generation
I I think you were palpably
uncomfortable that was one of those
times where I was like you know what
there is no hiding when you when you
have a three camera system yeah people
are going to watch me crawling out of my
skin on YouTube I actually think we need
a four camera system because you're
your giveaway nervous tick is when when
your leg starts fidgeting yeah at that
particular rate because you you do
fidget yeah but it's like um
it's generally like a metronomic uh
fidget yeah but when you when it
accelerates and becomes syncopated you
know like the difference between like
normal snoring and like sleep apnea
snoring like there's there's a
qualitative difference
um yeah we we need a leg cam uh and then
then people will be able to tell you
know we could just like so when I was
working on my PhD I did a lot of
um cardiometabolic Assessments in real
time uh you know so we would have
screens going where we would have an EKG
continuously and sometimes continuous uh
blood pressure monitoring we could just
do that uh so if if we really want to
help people see my discomfort and you
know stay on brand was Stronger by
science we can get a fourth camera feed
that's just a screenshot like a screen
capture of just my real-time uh blood
pressure and heart rate we could uh we
we could get like the the little finger
sensors that they use for like lie
detector tests that don't really tell if
you're lying but tell if you're nervous
because it's looking at like skin
reactants
um
yeah that would be cool yeah so uh
anyway a little aside but we will be
back uh most likely in seven days so
thanks for joining us
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]